hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar comprehensive
enumeration of mune cells in solid
tumors I am to do work of lab roots and
I'll be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by eye on path eye
on path is a venture-backed commercial
stage company founded by Stanford
researchers out of the lab of dr. Gary
Nolan the company is focused on
revolutionising pathology with multiplex
ion beam imaging MIDI technology newbee
is a multiplex imaging platform with
unmatched resolution sensitivity and
throughput to learn more visit WWII
empath calm let's get started you can
post questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind
to do so simply type them into the drop
down box located on the far left of your
screen labeled ask a question and click
on the send button questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today speaker Mike Angelo MD PhD
principal investigator at the Stanford
Blood Center dr. Angelo's academic
background spans the fields of physics
biochemistry electrical engineering and
medicine during his residency and
clinical pathology at the University of
California San Francisco dr. Angelo
became interested in developing novel
methods for immuno his
so chemical multiplexing using mass
spectrometry this led to the development
of MIDI during his postdoctoral work in
the Noland lab at Stanford University
dr. Angelou is now interested in
optimizing MIDI and other mass reporter
based technologies further with the goal
of identifying new transcriptional and
translational signatures in solid tissue
malignancies and in allergic and other
immunological disorders to help improve
clinical diagnosis and treatment dr.
Angelou will now begin his presentation
hi thank you for the introduction my
name is Micah Angelo's I'm in the
pathology department at Stanford and
they're really happy to be able to talk
with everyone that is doing this
presentation today about some of the
work that we've been doing with
multiplex ion beam imaging in my lab so
we've recently developed new
instrumentation for performing these
assays over the last couple of years and
most recently we just published a paper
you look at using maybe to look at a
cohort of triple negative breast cancer
tumors and found some very interesting
things there pertaining to checkpoint
protein expression amongst immune cell
subsets and how that is related to the
histological composition of tumors so
today I'm going to be going over sort of
the basic workflow principles of Mitte
and after going through that and and the
capabilities that you can do with this
platform and why you would even want to
you know bother using a mass spec
platform instead of something like a
fluorescence based platform I was going
to then talk to you all about some of
the interesting exciting findings that
we found in this triple negative breast
cancer cohort and discuss a little bit
the computational approaches that we use
to get there so to start off maybe is an
imaging workflow that is that uses metal
conjugated primary antibodies similar to
reporter based assays you might have
seen previously for a flow cytometry
like redoubt with mass cytometry
everything that we do in my lab is with
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded tissue
and usually archived with your materials
you can use other types of tissue I get
asked a lot whether or not you can use
like frozen's and stuff like that and
all those things are compatible my lab
has chose has chosen to focus on using
human FFPE samples because of the very
large number of samples that are in
clinical archives and many times have
long term follow-up
attached to them so everything that
we've done has been developed and
optimized and validated with those types
of samples in mind so essentially the du
Midi
it's very much like a regular ICS a you
mount the tissue want a slide which you
can see here in the cartoon then after
that the tissue is treated with a single
master mix of primary antibody for all
of the proteins that you're interested
in and that can vary from 10 up to 30 or
40 primary antibodies and each one of
those primary antibodies is tagged with
the unique elemental reporter and so the
little different colored different
colored balls as you see attached here
to the antibody there's like four four
antibody each one of the different
colors essentially represent you know
tags with different masses and
ultimately that's going to be what we're
able to map spatially in the tissue is
where those antibodies adhere to the
tissue and therefore where those metals
are localized spatially so but before I
get to that so the tissue is treated
with the primary mix of antibodies after
there's no second for those of you that
have done ihd staining before
fluorescence assays this is purely a
primary antibody assay so there's no
secondary amplification or secondary
antibodies after that points and so the
excess antibody master mixes rinse the
way we dry it out usually by putting it
in a vacuum jar under house back for
like an hour
and then after that we put it inside the
custom-built mass spectrometer that we
use to do this essay and and when we do
that that is equipped with a with an ion
gun a primary ion gun and second that it
shoots it accelerates charged massive
particles these can be either oxygen
ions or xenon ions or argon ions or old
multitude different things but but you
have a massive you know elemental or dye
molecular
particle that is ionized and it's
focused a very fine spot and that spot
size can be anywhere from two microns
down like 100 nanometers and that spot
is goes across the tissue pixel-by-pixel
and so for each pretend so it sits on a
single pixel for a set amount of time
and while it's doing that it liberate
all of these elemental reporters that
are that were attached to the antibodies
and stuck to the tissue does it and you
can see that as a stream of sort of
colored colored primary secondary ions
that are coming off those secondary
elemental ions are then transported
through the secondary through some ion
optics which enrich for these elements
elemental reporters that we care about
preferentially over ions that are
arising that are comprised of organic
material that might interfere with a
with a mass spectral analysis so we can
filter out the vast majority of those to
where ultimately what's delivered to the
mass spec at the end which is the time
of flight mass spectrometer and a stream
of secondary ions that's heavily
enriched for elemental species and so
then what we have is is for every single
pixel in the image we have a mass
spectrum associated with each one of
those pixels and so and you can see that
here there's kind of an example of three
pixels with the call-outs that go over
to the mass spectra that each pixel has
and that means that for each one little
colored Peaks that you see there we can
pick one one of the peaks and we can
generate a grayscale image that shows
the spatial distribution and therefore
the abundance of the antibodies which
are targeted towards the proteins of
interest so for example what you're
looking at here and everything that
you're going to see in this presentation
today
none of these images were generated with
any sort of light microscopy visas this
is all ion image data so where we've
essentially taken the intensity
these different metal reporters in each
pixel and encoded it as a grayscale
value in the picture so for example the
one you're looking at right now is the
antibody that we use is our nuclear
marker which is a we either use that
anybody towards double-stranded DNA or
histone h3 is if I blow this up you can
see that this is human tonsil and we
like to use tonsil for a lot of our our
QC and validation because my labs very
interested in immune cell subsets
particularly in particularly in within
the immune oncology space so we spent a
lot of time selecting reagents
validating them first by chromogenic IHC
and then looking at them using midi and
so a tonsil lymph nodes fleeing are all
immune rich organs that we use on a
frequent basis to do this and so because
you know MIDI is not a magic box so you
know it is it's still very much
dependent on the reagents the quality of
the reagents that you're using the
antibody reagents that you're using and
how well those reagents have been
tighter dand validated and so a very
important part of getting good data out
is to make sure that the validation is
done is done robustly and thoroughly so
I'm just going to show you some of the
results now what good antibody staining
looks like for us once we validated
every agent so if for those of you that
may may or may not be immunologist
essentially if you're looking at immune
cell subsets and tonsil it's very useful
because most of them are you can usually
find about everything you're looking for
in tonsil but tonsil can kind of be
broken down into general regions and so
in Grain this ball like structure is
what's called a you know a follicle or a
germinal Center and in red you have the
inner follicular region and so the
germinal centers
usually enriched in b-cells why the red
region the inner follicular regions is
usually more t-cell enriched although
even if they're still even within each
one of those regions you still see some
scattered cell types that are different
in learning engine thought just to step
through and show you exactly why this is
useful for instance let's say for T and
B cells so we know the T cells as
opposed to discussing more T cells and
inner follicular regions and so here you
can see that we are the cd3 which is a
specific lineage marker for T cells is a
well enriched along that border between
the germinal Center in the inner
follicular regions where at cd20 is in
the germinal center and is green and you
can see it's we have a nice discreet
border there delineating between T and B
cells so now I'm just going to step
through and show you some different
immune cells subsets and so the one
thing to remember when you're looking at
this data is that all of this data the
tissue would stain simultaneously with
all the antibodies and all of those
antibody channels were read out
simultaneously so this is in no way a
cyclical process so if you look here to
look at specific T cell subsets the two
major subsets most people think about is
cd4 T cells and cd8 t-cells and so T
cells should either Express cd4 or cd8
although you know there is occurrence of
double positive cd4 cd8 cells but
they're usually very low in abundance so
you know in general we should mostly see
that see we should mostly see cells that
are red and green or red and blue but
not red green and blue and so you can
see here then that that's by and large
what we see we see orthogonal
co-expression of CD 3 with 4 or 8 but in
general not 4 and 8 and so kind of
digging into that a little further we
can then look at even more granular
levels of t-cell subsets and look at Co
expression within cd4 T cells of either
Fox p3 or PT 1 and so PD 1 is a target
that's a a
you know of a lot of interest right now
in immunotherapy trials there's an CPT
one monoclonal antibodies that are used
to treat multiple cancers now and so you
can see here the sort of classic
expression pattern of pd-1 bright PG one
expression of cd4 follicular helper
t-cells in the terminal Center is easily
delineated and at Fox p3 which marks
which marks regulatory t-cells is
nuclear and within safety for positive
cells as well so now just to kind of
walk through a little more quickly some
other examples or cd45 ro which marks a
memory t-cells lack 3 which is another
checkpoint t-cell receptor and here you
can see ki67 which is a marker
proliferation again a nuclear marker and
you can see that in cd20 again which is
marking b-cells and we just put cd20
here along with HLA dr to show that B
cells which are antigen presenting cells
also Express a lot of that you see nice
Co expression of atrial ADR with CD 20
and then lastly just looking at some of
the some of the macrophage subsets that
are a lot of interest right now you can
see here CD 11 be Co expression with PDL
1 with in follicular dendritic cells and
also cd68 expression and some of the
macrophages on that germinal Center so
now you know that's sort of what we feel
like the markers should look like in the
same quality that you get once you are
in the areas you've got a well validated
panel and markers that and you've
selected anybody's perform well on the
sample type of interest and kind of
shift gears and talking about what are
the performance metrics is maybe the
sort of real-world performance metric
that you can expect and so on the right
here this is a example of an image that
we acquired recently in a study we're
doing with carrying a down steep galley
we were looking at GI biopsies from
patients with peanut allergy
and right there you can see that pink
the cell in there it's in pink that's
showing Co expression of mass felt
ripped days and kinase that we're
looking at mass cells within the gut and
this is I put up this image because this
is in general I think this is probably
the higher end of resolution that you
can achieve with this platform which is
probably on the order of two to three
hundred nanometer resolution but just
kind of step through and show you
principle the resolution range is
between 100 nanometers and 10 microns
although 100 nanometers and practice can
be very difficult to get to not
necessarily because of the capabilities
of the system but simply because of
vibrations most the time and the
facilities that the systems could be
housed in so for instance were on the
second floor and and and vibrations
within the room end up being a limiting
factor for us on a lot of stuff we can
resolve so we typically can't get much
lower than around to 250 nanometers or
so secondly the field of view size is
essentially can be set instantly it went
electronically we can go anywhere from a
field of view size down to a micron all
the way up to one and a half millimeters
we get we we've been able to test and
show that around 55 different metal tags
can be conjugated to antibodies and use
them spelled read out
and the sensitivity that we've been able
to estimate with recent benchmarking
experiments indicates that our
sensitivity is on the order of around
one to five antibodies per pixel and the
pixel rate which is how many pixels we
can acquire is around up to ten thousand
pixels per second although in practice
right now I think we rarely exceed
around one to two thousand pixels per
second so then you know one of the
questions that becomes is you know and a
lot of people see this they say oh well
why not just do everything at high
resolution right um well there's reason
and the reason is is that maybe is like
a lot of other imaging platforms and the
respect that you can you can go
high-resolution and one thing is unique
about maybe is that when you go to
higher resolution it's you do not lose
any sensitivity but what you do the
trade-off that you do get is that the
acquisition speeds go up significantly
the higher the resolution you want to
you want to run at so you'd be kind of a
feel for that this is a single nucleus
that we crop from an image that shows
what sort of features you can delineate
at resolutions that we sort of say or
serve a low res medium resin high res
and so so the typical scan times and at
these different resolutions for a half
millimeter field of view just to give
you an idea this so you can see the high
res which is the one that's all the way
over to the right you know about 250
nanometer resolution is going to take a
is going to take it probably at least
one from half hours if not more that you
know one and a half hours it's probably
an optimistic estimate at a resolution
that high where you have you know highly
abundant markers but at that resolution
you can see that you can you can easily
delineate here we have the two grayscale
channels for double-stranded DNA and if
your laminae see which marks a nuclear
envelope but you can see that this
resolution we can actually see the finer
features the nuclear envelope in the
shape of the chromatin
in the laminae sea channel and also you
can see that you can see the the nuclear
features more clearly in the DNA channel
as well
as you go up to low lower lower
resolution you can see that we start to
lose some of the resolving power for
those features until you get to the
survey scan to where you can definitely
resolve the nucleus itself but we really
have it we really cannot see any of the
intra nuclear morphology now the thing
is though is that at that survey scan
resolution that field only takes around
15 seconds or so so as compared with one
and a half hours a 250 nanometer
resolution so you can imagine then that
there's this push and pull between
resolution and acquisition speeds is is
a very important factor to think about
when designing maybe experiment now the
one thing I will point out though is
that as you can probably tell from this
series of images is that all of these
images will rescan of the vac same field
of view in the tissues so each one of so
we acquired these images at these
resolutions by taking a scan of the
field 250 nanometer resolution and
changing the resolution and rescanning
that same exact the field is 500
nanometer resolution and so on and so
forth and so this gets to a really I
think important distinctive feature the
platform is um you know acquisition time
is important and it's something that you
have to factor in when you're trying to
decide how to design these experiments
but um you can rescan the samples which
means that you can actually use maybe
much like a regular microscope and what
do I mean by that I mean so it means
that you can go and you can look at very
large areas and so I'm going to show you
example here where we look at entire
tissue section and we can acquire all of
the antibodies channels at that time and
we do at a low resolution which allows
us to cover a very large area relatively
quickly we can then review those that
serve a region and we can identify
regions that we
you're interesting and then we can go
back in and rescan those interesting
regions at higher resolutions so you
know this is is a sort of analogous the
way you know sort of a practicing
pathologist operates when they're
looking at slides right which is that
they review the slide at low power they
find regions they think are interesting
or probative for the questions that
they're asking and then they go and they
investigate those regions at a higher
magnification so to give you an idea
what that looks like this is a full
tissue section that we tiled but I think
this is over around five 550 individual
fields of view that were tiled together
to get this cohesive view of the entire
tissue section and so and so here you
can see carrot environment and SMA and
I've gated out these two regions here r1
and r2 which you can and so the reason I
wanted to show you these was that we can
then if we look at these two regions and
we look at the multi-channel data from
these two regions so we're still looking
at the survey image data here you can
see that they have you know in both
cases this is a triple negative breast
cancer tumor in both cases uh you know
we're seeing care and expression in the
tumor cells but in the case of r2 that
that local field of view has tumor cells
that Express site occurred six whereas
our one does not um and the other thing
that we see is that is that r1 has a
relative enrichment of cd45 positive
immune cells and the tumor is apparently
expressing HLA dr which you know to
class two protein and so if we go back
in in this regions now and we look at
higher res images of those though these
are these are fields of view that were
then rescan based on that survey
information
we can see that there is there is we can
now see with much finer detail where the
tumor cells are and in particular in the
case of our one on the Left where all
these different immune cells are and so
and in each one of these inset you see
we've zoomed in and can see so the
juxtaposition of interesting immuno
regulatory proteins and different immune
cell subsets so this kind of gives you
an idea of this microscope like workflow
then that you can do with maybe where
you can go back and forth between sort
of lower res survey scans and follow up
higher res scans it can be used for
segmentation downstream image analysis
the one other thing which you might
might have occurred you as we're talking
here is that um is that you know as
people often say it's like well if you
rescan it you know maybe is a semi
destructive process you must be going
into the tissue and that's exactly right
so with each scan of the field we're
probably taking off around we estimate
around the top 100 to 200 nanometers so
if you stay on the same field and use
the same conditions and you and you do
multiple you do multiple images we can
actually start to see the information
about the tissue structure so this is a
small field this is 100 micron field of
view of melanoma and one of the things
I've highlighted here so you see in
green so DNA is is in green and sodium
potassium ATPase is in blue and in red
is by mittens and so the this dot this
area where I've got the dotted line once
you give an eye on that nucleus and
these other areas of the solid lines is
no nucleus there but as I step through
the plains you can see that the nucleus
that was on top is now going away and
those circled regions you can start to
see nuclei emerged I step through here
to where when we finally get to the last
frame you can see that now there's no
nucleus where there was one and you've
got these two nuclei that are now at the
top that are that are at the top of the
field and also very interestingly where
there was just nucleus now we not only
see
no nucleus but we also see the my mitten
and sodium-potassium ATPase signals that
have come in so we're seeing the
disappearance of nuclear signal and the
emergence of membrane and cytoplasmic
signal and reciprocal fashion one other
last advantage of this being a mass spec
platform is it maybe has complete
elemental coverage of the periodic table
elemental coverage so there's a lot of
things that we can look at that are
dodges to the tissue itself that can
inform our analysis so for instance we
can see phosphorus which is within the
nuclei of obviously because the high
degree of phosphate content DNA and that
overlays nicely with the DNA anybody we
can also see carbon which serves as sort
of like a nice negative stain to the
tissue itself and more from a more
functional perspective the other thing
we can do is we can see transition
metals that are involved in biological
processes like iron and so here we're
visualizing splenic macrophages and so
what's your CD 60 a positive but the
other thing is is that the top field
there you can see the ones labeled iron
so we're actually looking at
intracellular sequestered iron within
these macrophages and you can see if
those macrophages they not only have
sequestered iron but they have also in
response to that iron sequesteration
have up regulated an enzyme called heme
oxygenase one which is involved in
porphyrin catabolism and so in this
sense it's kind of cool because you can
also probe some of these other metals
that are known to be involved both in
physiologic and pathologic pathologic
biological processes so now sort of
shift gears in terms of applications as
we were very happy we just recently had
our first paper accepted about a week or
two ago it was on triple negative breast
cancer a great large portion this work
was done by the first author leox Rena
did a beautiful job at the computational
analysis and I think that's the other
thing I wanted to spend the second half
of this presentation on is talking about
like how do we construct a cohort
we use this tool then to look at a
patient cohort in a meaningful way and
what are sort of some general heuristics
that you know are you know good sort of
reference points for how to go about
these analyses so we went and we examine
41 triple negative breast cancer
patients these were all archival samples
from the Stanford tissue bank that had
come into Stanford over the last 10
years we had clinical follow-up data on
all these patients that we could see a
disease-free survival overall survival
and and we were able to correlate those
things at the analysis that we did and
so we were very interested here and
looking at the immune cell subsets
presence and these tumors they can see
the staining panel that we did was
highly biased in that respect towards
looking at immune cell subsets as well
as checkpoint expression so in a study
like this you know the first question is
it's like you know what are the main
goals of the image post-processing
analysis and so this is where I think
there's going to be a lot of really
exciting work done over the next few
years sort of this evolving art of how
to interpret high dimensional imaging
data and so and so I think you know the
first one that might occur everybody
right is we want to we want to know
which cell phenotypes are present and
and how significant numbers of those
cells present and then if an imaging
assays obviously we want to know is
there anything important about each each
one of these cell populations and how
they're structurally organized relative
to one another
and then lastly arm you know is you're
going to find to the one word of you
know the one word of caution I would
give us any any high dimensional
technique whether it's you know maybe or
you know even anything else where you
have a lot of parameters is that you're
going to find something you'll always
find something so the the big question
is is can you is there some sort of you
know endpoint or clinical outcome that
you can correlate the data that you're
getting out with so that you can kind of
sift through this large multitude of
findings to find the things that may
seem to be most relevant to
problem and so this is something that we
try to focus on very hard in my lab is
uh not only the data analysis but in the
initial construction of the patient
cohort that we're sort of setting
ourselves up to be able to answer those
types of questions but so the first
thing then is before we go do anything
is we need to somehow get these images
and get them into a form where we can
extract information about individual
cells so the first step in that is you
essentially need to have a way to draw
the borders around each individual cell
within the image and so this is called
image segmentation usually it starts
with with drawing borders around the
nuclei of cells and one of the things
that we found was that a lot of the
existing tools for this that they tend
to not work really well in images where
there's where the cell shape can vary a
lot and so if you have a bunch of small
cells a bunch of big cells is the the
existing tools seem to do well in one or
the other but it was hard to get them to
work well everything at once and so we
worked with the Damon van Valen lab at
Caltech to be able to build upon their
previous work on using deep cell which
was originally done for segmenting
bacterial and microscope images and we
used it here - it's a convolutional
neural network approach and we were able
to relatively short order to feed in
some training data to get the nuclear
segmentation to work appreciably better
so you can see here the segments the
neural network that we're using is in
green and in red is the output from
elastic which is a tool which is a tool
that's been out for a while that you
know works reasonably well but has
problems where there's a lot of
differences and chromatin so I've been
very happy with this and we're building
upon this right now to hopefully end up
with a a convolutional neural network
pipeline they can do full cell
segmentation and sort of multicellular
feature recognition we're hoping to move
that along within the next 12 months or
so but once you have the single
features drawn we can then add together
all of the signal for each anybody in
each cell and essentially generate
something that would be similar to like
a SES file for flow cytometry where we
have every single cell and we have the
total amount of protein and the
different not only within the cell
except but within different sub cellular
compartments of whether its nuclear
cytoplasmic and then we also have the
the spatial coordinates for those cells
so the first thing we do then is we just
simply do a clustering to identify
unique cell clusters and phenotypes in
this case we disclose them and so you
can see there that essentially what
comes out is sort of the major immune
cell subsets that allow people
interested in so and now that we have
those we can actually go through and map
back on to the original data using just
a color map where the different immune
cell subsets are so for instance and
just a and just to show you going back
to the primary antibody imaging data you
can see this yellows these yellow cells
are cd20 positive whereas that one
orange cell in there is CB 56 positive
which is four and and the yellow cells
are b-cells the orange cells are in k
cells so you know the the algorithm is
by no means perfect but by and large we
found the assignment accuracy to be to
be pretty good and and definitely
sufficient for the questions that we
wanted to ask here so then sort of
asking okay so what does it look like
then if we look at these 42 patients
this shows you the pseudo colored or
high-level view of all 42 patients and
what you see then is right it's a grey
as tumor and anything is not gray is a
different type of immune cells so you
know the one thing that jumps out to you
probably is that there's definitely
there's two big differences amongst
these you know there's a lot of tumors
that don't have very many of you so all
and then other one and then there's some
tumors that have a ton of immune cells
and the abundance of which immune cells
are there the relative makeup can vary
pretty dramatically so you can see that
here so if we look at patient sixteen
compared to patient 24 facie 24 has
essentially you know nothing but Mac
spacious and also has a very low number
of immune cell whereas page 16 has a
wide diversity of immune cells and is a
very very different composition so one
of the first things we saw is if we went
and we took all of those patients and we
ordered them if we sorted them according
to how many immune cells they had in
their tumors we found that there was a
stepwise progression of which immune
cell lineages about essentially that
certain immune cell lineages the
presence of those was contingent upon
the presence of other immune cells so
what I mean by that so essentially if we
look at let's say b-cells
every single tumor we looked at if it
had b-cells they're also cd4 T C D APs
and macrophages on any tumor that had
any immune cells at all always had
macrophages there and this sort of makes
sense and we think that these ones that
have only macrophages could well be what
we probably are reading out is the is
the tissue resident macrophages within
the tissue but there was a stepwise
recruitment that was very striking and
you know and probably most striking was
the presence of natural killer cells was
completely correlated 100% of the time
with the presence of macrophages
deviates Igor's and B cells on similar
fashion if we look sort of a checkpoint
expression within these tumors we also
saw that there was a heavy inter
dependence of the presence of checkpoint
and other immune regulatory proteins
with one another so for instance every
single every single tumor that had a
high number of T regs also had cells
that Express lagg-3 p1 PDL one and I do
now
the question is which cell types now
that we've identified all these
different cell types which ones are Co
localized more frequently than you would
expect by chance and so that's the big
thing which one how can we then ask
questions in a sort of a large data set
in a statistically valid fashion so
where we can tease out which when you
see Co approximation of two cell types
that when we see that we know that it is
something that probably could not have
happened randomly and so the big thing
to think about when asking these types
of questions is that when you look at a
tissue section as you saw in those other
examples the abundance of a particular
cell population can vary dramatically
right I mean some of these tumors have
5000 immune cells in a single field
whereas some of them only have thirty
mewn cells some of these tumors have you
know and huge huge numbers of cd4 cd8
and some of them have nothing but
macrophages so so the abundance of the
cell populations and very dramatically
not only that then where these different
cell types are located within the tumors
can also very simply based on the innate
sort histological properties of the
tissue we're looking at so then what we
want to do is we want to come up with a
way to be able to look at the co
approximation of two different cell
types and know that even if we account
for the number the total abundance of
those different cell types and the
inherent sort of tissue structure that
it's more likely than not that those two
cell types preferentially ended up next
to one another because of factors other
than what we would expect just by random
chance because there's just so many of
them so so here's an example here's a
little cartoon of a tumor where we have
a population of green cells and a
population of red cells and so the
question is when I asked in is this way
is is are the red cells next to the
green cells is that a preferential
interaction or they just next to each
other because there just happened to be
lots of green cells this is in the
you know many many more Greenville's and
there are red cells and so that naughty
is there's essentially nowhere else for
the red bills to be other than the green
cells so the best way to ask that
question then is is do take this tumor
and we're going to we're going to keep
the we're going to keep the green cell
to just phenotype one we're going to
keep all those in the same place and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to go and we're going to randomize
the location of all the red cells to all
the different cell positions within the
tumor and each time we do a
randomization that's going to be like
one sort of randomized to her and we're
going to we're going to essentially make
around you know 10,000 different
randomizations like that and so what
that does is in is is that for each one
of those randomizations we can look at
sort of a pairwise distance matrix to
know what the average distance between a
red cell and a green cell is and we do
that for the randomized samples to get
or to get a statistical distribution of
what it looks like when the when the
tissues been randomized and we then
compare that with the actual original
sample and by doing that we're able to
generate a z-score for the statistical
significance of those pairwise
interactions and so here and so how do
we use this so one of the first things
we did was looking very generally it's
sort of if we look purely at all the
different markers and did pairwise you
know randomized that pairwise a pairwise
distance matrix where we use this
randomization to attain these cores
which markers are Co localized more
often than not and one of the first
things we saw was that there in some
tumors there was a high preference for
tumor markers and immune markers to be
Co localized but for immunity mer
markers to be sort of mutually exclusive
to one another at least spatially so
whereas in other tumors we found that
this wasn't true at all and that really
didn't seem to be much of a difference
in how immune markers and tumor markers
were located within the tissue and you
can actually see that in these pseudo
coloured image is that these two tumor
fields the tumor cells here in blue
immune cells are an orange
so you see that the one on the left will
resolve this Co this co-localization
with tumor or with immune but not
between the two that there is this
interesting sort of compartmentalized
phenotype of the tumor where the immune
cells and the tumor cells are segregated
away from one another whereas in there's
another phenotype that we see on the
right which is a mixed phenotype where
tumor cells and immune cells eview much
more admixed and there is a little bit
of a relationship with whether things
are compartmentalize or mixed
based on the total number of immune
cells there but by and large this seems
to be another axis to describe these
types of tumors of whether or not
they're cold which is where they have
very few immune cells that are or what
we think is sort of the more intriguing
case at least for this study which is in
the case where there are significant
number of ribbing cells are these tumors
mixed or compartmentalised and so we're
able to make that distinction than
purely based remains making an unbiased
way purely based on these distance
matrices to be able to classify these
tumors and so one of the interesting
things we immediately saw with this was
that was looking at PDL one expression
and so pto one checkpoint protein that
is also targeted by by monoclonal
therapeutics the interesting thing about
PDL one is that it can be expressed both
by tumor and it can also be expressed by
immune cells and this is actually
something that can be sort of difficult
to delineate in regular chromogenic IHC
and so what we found was was that if you
broke down PDL one expression to repeal
one expression in the immune cell
pre-video one expression you look at
that ratio the ratio of the number of
PDL one positive tumor cells the PDL and
positive immune cells for each patient
what we found was the compartmentalised
tumors were heavily biased at having PDL
and expression on immune cells whereas
these mixed tumours were much more
likely to appeal an expression on tumor
cells and as an example here as you can
see also that if we just simply
enumerate all the PDL 1 positive tumor
cells and tumor that if you look at the
you look at the number that we see in
the mix compared with it
compartmentalizes farm or PTO on
positive tumor cells in the mixed
histological group that in the
compartment Alliance group this sort of
just shows examples of those two types
those two histological types the patient
33 is was classified as mixed and you
can see PDO one expression is on tumor
cells and as patient five is classified
as compartmentalised and we see a heavy
preference for PDL one expression to be
on the immune cell now similarly another
thing that we saw was an ideal
expression which is which we found was
there wasn't as much of a sort of
one-to-one difference between tumor and
immune as we saw a PDL on but what we
did see was ieo expression in general
when it was there there was a heavy bias
for city-owned immune cells in the
compartmentalized tumors and lastly
which is also very interesting was that
we found that there was a very big
preference for pd-1 positivity the PD
one being the t-cell checkpoint receptor
to win it to be on cd4 t-cells in the
compartmentalized tumors whereas there
was a much higher degree of CDA p1 cells
and the mixed tumours and so now we're
painting a picture we're just simply
based on the relative spatial spatial
distribution of the immune cells and
tumor cells we see that PDL one
expression seems to be its disposition
whether it's on immune cells a tumor
cells seems to be highly correlated with
that as the presence of ideal and immune
cells as well as whether or not PD one
expression is preference toward cd4
t-cells or cd8 t-cells
now if we look closer at the
compartmentalized tumors and we wanted
nice things that we can do with this
data is we can also go and we can break
down each of the compartmentalized
tumors into into three regions and where
we can look at six different cell
phenotypes and so we can look at and
here you see there's a light blue and
sort of an orange region that identifies
the tumor immune border and so the light
blue region is the tumor side of that
and the orange is the abuse side at that
border the dark blue is what we would
sort of we've gated out as being the
tumor bulk and the red is what we're
talking about is being sort of the
mutant bulk and so we can now see cells
that are at the immune cells that are at
the tumor review board or tumor cells or
the two ramune border we can see tumor
cells that are within the bulk immune
cells that are within the bulk and then
also very interestingly we can also
identify immune cells that have
penetrated into the tumor bulk as well
as tumor cells that have penetrated into
the immune bulk and so one of the first
things that we saw if we just look at
the tumor immune interfaces it seems to
be a very interesting gradients of
expression that lie along that border
and so one is that we when we've seen
this in several tumors since then is
that if you look at to the epigenetic
modifiers that we looked at here which
were post translational modifications
for histone h3 you can see that for h3k9
a set elation in k-27 trimethylation at
that tumor immune border there is a
heavy bias towards set elation that then
transitions toward a bias for
trimethylation as you move away from the
tumor immune border and we were able to
see this in multiple tumors as you can
see on the wilcoxon rank-sum and see but
and so we went and we looked at this for
to see if there were other sort of
representative motifs where we saw heavy
enrichment of certain expression
phenotypes
preferentially at the border and one of
the ones we saw that was very
interesting was it right at the tumor
immune border there was because there
was a group of compartmentalised tumors
that had this heavy enrichment of I do
of immune cells of the immune side to
express I do P do 1c elevenses 11 B but
very interestingly on the tumor side the
tumours that up regulated HLA had
operated MHC class 2 in the form of HLA
dr and so um that this was a you know
we're now looking to look at this at
this tumor immune interface and this
cohort more closely to see if this is
indeed possibly related to a focal up
regulation of interferon gamma but I
think the main reason to care about all
of these findings is that is that is
that we went back after the fact
and looked at outcome data between
simply looking if we cut if it classify
these as compartmentalised or mixed and
what we found was it was a very big
difference in survival between tumors
that were classified as compartmentalize
the tumors that were classified as mixed
the compartmentalised tumors surviving
for longer seemingly longer periods of
time we think that this could well be a
marker of chemo responsiveness and
triple negative breast cancer but we're
following up on this right now with uh
with a withheld cohort to see if that
pans out it and and those samples as
well so um the last thing I would say is
that if you want to look at the data we
have all of the data up regulated to an
online web viewer where you can you can
toggle through all 42 tumors you can
make color overlays of any of the
channels that we measure and so just to
give you an idea what that looks like
here's I am passes posting the data for
us and this is one of tumors one of the
compartmentalised tumors kind of like
what I was talking about before you can
see here this sort of bright mimd bright
rich mint of cells that are 11 C and C
16 positive right at the tumor immune
interface and you know and so you and
within the interface you can zoom in and
zoom out to take a look so again you
know if you zoom in you can take a
better look at like what those different
immune cell subsets look like so it's
very nice and if you'd like to get an
idea of you know exactly what all of it
looks like it's really great interface
for exploring the data you can also from
here of course download all the data as
tips if you want to look at it within
you with your own imaging tools and so
with that I just like to really thank
Leah Corinne who did a huge amounts of
the work on this paper and the very
elegant computational analysis if you
saw she's done a really great job with
it and is continuing to work to build
out that computational pipelines that
can be used for other disease types and
and hopefully something that might be a
little more turnkey and then
not-too-distant future for for labs that
have a ton of biological expertise but
maybe don't have the people in-house
that can you know generate a lot of
these computational pipelines and also
to Erin McCaffrey who did a lot of the
work with that you saw looking at the
splenic macrophages and lastly to mark
Bo's a who is the in-house instrument
extraordinary guru who has the Manning
all of this stuff with a different
tissue cohort and so with that I would
really just like to thank all of our
collaborators and particularly big thank
you to the NIH for funding this work at
such an early stage to the early
independence award and with that I'm
happy to take any questions
you
Thank You dr. Angelou for you
patience quick reminder for our audience
on how to submit questions simply type
them into the drop-down box located on
the far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button dr. Angelo will answer as
many questions as time permits first
question is where would you purchase
antibodies with elemental metal
conjugated
and
for that one let me know if you want me
to repeat it
oh sorry can you hear me now yes
perfectly no no so the the the anti
empathic companies commercializing
technology is going to be offering up a
product line of metal conjugated
antibodies but you can also metal
conjugate your own reagents if you have
primary antibodies in-house just using
metal conjugation kids that they also
are selling the big thing to remember
with that is that the when doing the
reaction to tether the metal key later
tact is the antibody you need to have
anybody in a format where the buffer
doesn't contain any protein so it needs
to be in a protein carrier free format
so there's BSA in there or any other
sort of stabilizing protein carrier
it'll interfere with the conjugation so
just remember that if you're going to
get Rivet eyes your own primary antibody
they need to be at a purified format
thank you next one is when doing the
incubation with all the CAD antibodies
how do you control with such variations
between antibodies like antigen
retrieval solutions and time incubation
just to mention two factors
it's a great question so we have found
so we try to wit we've pretty much
picked a single epitope retrieval
condition and we try to harmonize all of
our reagents to that so a lot of work
has been done over the last you know
five 10 years especially in the anatomic
pathology space where they've gone
through source systematically compared
the different epitope retrieval
protocols and you know essentially that
the old-school way of doing it is uh is
you know to use the model acidic citrate
buffer the within the last maybe five
ten years alkaline buffers like tryst
tryst EDTA have become pretty popular
and we found and this is verified and a
fair number of papers that um that seems
to be pretty cross compatible with most
antibodies you know not all I think the
stats that I've read on is you just
receive EPA for around 95 percent of
reagent so the now the question is is
that it I think the thing is that people
when they conventionally think about
this they're going and they're trying to
pick the epitope retrieval condition
that gives the absolute most intense
staining and so what we found is you
know sometimes if you use Tris and
citrate maybe one of the other looks a
little bit better or but we're more by
and large we're able to get the
performance that we want is using
tricity TPA
thank you next one is how is it possible
to rescan if the tissue is damaged due
to the laser and is it performed on
cereal sections so well the first thing
is to remember about this and one of the
things that makes the platform I think
different right is that is that there's
the the method which we which we
liberate secondary ions is not with a
laser it's with a particle beam and so
you know a laser being you know just
like this is a particle beam meaning
they were actually shooting charged ions
you know atoms that have had electrons
removed at the surface and so in doing
this where it this is it's based on a
mythical secondary ion mass spectrometry
which has been around for many decades
and use pretty heavily in the
semiconductor industry and some other
areas and one of the reasons they like
it so much is because the erosion rate
of how quickly you burrow through a
specimen is very very can be very finely
controlled actually to a degree that's
far greater than anything you would eat
here I mean you know that Intel does
stuff like this where they're milling
craters with Simms beam from the order
of a few nanometers essentially though
what that means is that as we're milling
through the tissue with each pass we use
like standard 4 micron thick sections
and with each pass we're removing a
small fraction of the bulk as we go over
it so we're usually only removing maybe
the top hundred 200 nanometers or so and
so that means then that we can
sequentially scan the samples and and
and get you know repeats gang and either
derive the depth information or use that
as a means of you know going back and
forth between surveys and high-res
very good thank you what do you think is
the limiting factor with this technology
and how do you compare it with the
ablative technology and imaging math
cycle
so I mean the limiting factor here I
think and really with any of them is
going to be is going to be probably you
know sample throughput this isn't you
know if you look at this it's definitely
not at the point where you can do you
know an unlit you can essentially design
a study with was you know without any
regard of having to think about you know
how many samples you want to run so you
know now it's sort of like we wanted to
do a if you're just scanning you know a
Chinese or chromogenic stay neck with
some of the modern slide scanners those
slides extraordinarily fast I mean you
can do a ton of light based scans but
obviously you don't have the
multiplexing capability so you know I
think the I think the challenges in the
next few years or to you know to make
the the system you know build it to have
increased throughput and also make the
computational tools it's kind of a
learning to at the end more seamless and
and more turnkey in regards to
comparison with the blade of
technologies like the IMC I think that
really you know the few big differences
here and there's a reason that and
there's some reasons that we decided to
go down this road rather than you know
using a laser ablation technique one is
that you know the ionization yield and
sensitivity using Tim is a good bit
higher about 10 10 15 times higher than
you can get with the laser ablation
icp-ms
and a big reason to that is because you
know the ionization is performed in
vacuum and so there's no iron losses is
your whereas with the laser ablation
platforms laser ablation is actually
done under atmosphere and then it has to
be transported with a carrier gas and
into the plasma and then after gets out
of the plasma it's going into the vacuum
for the mass spec and there's a lot of
losses that are incurred there the other
big difference is the resolution you
know the laser ablation platforms I
think get between the spot size and
lasers in the order of like one or two
microns on the spot sizes we get here
good bit lower you know they're in order
of like two 300 nanometers if that's
what you
/ to run at although you know kind of
like that I talked about that does come
at a trade offs at some extent on on on
a throughput but the other is also you
know a sort of speed I think and so
there's really no upper limits that
would the pixel acquisition speeds with
with the MIDI because the ions are
extracted at such extremely high
velocities that we don't have problems
with pixel crosstalk even if we were
going as fast as like ten thousand
pixels per second and most of the laser
ablation platforms I think the fastest
they can go is around you know 100
hundred fifty pixels per second so
throughputs another really big
consideration and that and then the last
one I think is that you know in both
cases right I think that I'm even though
the system is faster even it's not so
fast that you know like we're saying you
could do anything that you wanted so one
thing that you can do here that you
can't do with the other ones is tissue
rescanning because laser ablation
platforms the pulse the pulse
variability of the laser is the cv is
very high so in order to get like
something consistent in your imaging you
essentially on the path to do full
tissue ablation you can't really do
rescanning so you know so that means
that essentially the throughput you have
the throughput that you have for us here
because we can go up and down and
dramatically increase throughput by
doing survey resolution you know we can
kind of exploit that to to do some
larger scale studies that might not be
possible otherwise thank you how many
reef scans can you perform without
degradation signals
hmm probably about I mean we can usually
hit eight to ten without much of a
problem although you know I mean that
does we have found that you know
different tissues seem to edge and
sputter away faster than others and so
the more connective tissue and fat you
know it seems to be more it seems to be
just probably just less material overall
but usually in general you know we're
looking at tumors or you know or pretty
much you know we look at brain or any
sort of you know wide spectrum of
samples usually get around ten good
least five it looks like we have time
for one more question
and it is were there any drastic
differences in the expression pattern of
the tumor cells between
compartmentalised tumor and mixed tumor
for example where the expression of pd-1
and PDL one on tumor cells very
different among the two types of tumor
yes so um one of the major differences
that we saw between the compartmentalize
in the IMP and the mixed tumours is that
you know the PDL one's very interesting
because it can be you know it can be
expressed on tumor cells or and immune
cells and one of the really striking
things that we found was that the mixed
tumours seemed to have a heavy heavy
predominance and excess of tumor cells
expressing PDL one what relative to the
compartmentalized tumors and the
compartmentalized tumors the PDL one
expression with by and large found on
immune cells and so there definitely was
this this correlation between the
histological distribution of the cell
types and the disposition of checkpoint
expressions
thank you I would like to once again
thank dr. Angelou for presentation you
have any final comments
no I was just going to say you know we
can there was a few things in here where
people were wanting to get links to the
data to the paper I think we can send
all that out and my feel free if anybody
has any questions more than welcome to
email me I'll try to get back with you
that is great thank you I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor ion paths for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through April 2019 lab routes will alert
you via email and it's available for
replaying we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye